we have 100 players on this server but
instead of imposters they're zombies
these zombies are going to flood us guys
if you get hit you lose
let's see if we can survive all five
rounds chandler you man the right
quatrain called the left quadrant doors
are up and go just don't get hit don't
get it oh my gosh i'm mowing them down
i'm mowing them down
they're coming i'm going in chris watch
my stick i got your six go in clear them
out right quadrant i got it oh wait
[Applause]
oh no they've got me surrounded oh
they're coming in the left they're
coming in the left
they're scared of me on the right oh
wait who's watching the right deal don't
leave the right i'm in reactor mowing
them down
look at the bodies oh my god there are
so many corpses
hey carl oh my gosh they're like hiding
in med bay be careful there's one in my
bed carl carl if you're here and i'm
here who's watching the south
wait wait carl if you're here and i'm
here who's watching the left
they're all in here go chris go lead the
way all right you know what screw
camping cafeteria let's be mid yeah
being chandler been clearing it out
jimmy jimmy come on let's push let's
push let's push
uh taylor watch out
i think they spawn in reactor they're
spawn camping bro come on let's go down
here let's go to electrical
these zombies are 100 real people oh
they're coming oh gosh hurry come on
are they in med bay any in med bay oh
one of us doing a scan i am on a tear
and if you guys thought this was crazy
just wait for the later rounds it gets
insane
murder
none of you will survive i'm gonna be
nice and not shoot him whoa chris come
on
yeah all right well nevermind yeah
they're spotted over here yeah
green boys whoa
we have one minute left in round one we
just gotta survive one more minute yeah
we're just literally spawning driving
him right now
look at the massacre around me look how
close i got oh my gosh i'm alone carl
i'm coming for you carl
let's go come on chris 10 seconds around
one is over protect me i'm sitting in my
chair you're just spinning your gun
three
two
one all right congratulations everybody
it is officially round two which means
their speed is about to double what
they're going to be zooming around
zooming in is round two watch out oh my
gosh look how much faster they are
there's so many on the right chandler
help me mow these john's down i'm
shooting them i'm shooting them if i
miss here i'm dead dude there's so many
there we should get in this corner no
you're gonna get stuck you're gonna get
stuck they're coming for me oh wait i'm
in med bay someone help me i'm in med
bay there's a lot there's a lot someone
come help me you're in med bay i got you
jimmy i got you and somebody come help
me help me come on jimmy hurry
oh my gosh the cabinetry is overtaken
wow they're everywhere you guys watch
the left side i walked right why are we
just chilling in a hallway what is that
guy doing down there i'm camping
electrical i'm in electrical that's it
guys you gotta help us fall back fall
back we gotta make a push i'm pushing oh
hey go right side push push punch punch
punch push come on
don't lay a finger on jimmy
oh my gosh he's faster than me what was
that dude hold on hold on we need to
strategize oh hey hey we're the same
color buddy buddy we're the same color
get away from me oh you guys are
matching how cute we all have to like
rush them at the same time yeah come to
electrical no trailer they're all
smoking jailers dead help
oh
no no oh i'm dead i think i'm dead dude
look at them they're just feasting on me
we lost jayla get down we lost chandler
guys guys guys i think this is where i
die i think this is where i die there's
so many how am i still alive nope nope
nope nope nope nope i'm in med bay let's
go get jimmy in med bay and bring him to
electrical come on chris green squad out
okay let's go this way too electrical
too electrical we are the rescue squad
follow us to safety we got 30 seconds
left in round two and then they speed up
again no
oh we got a horde coming they're gearing
up oh down in storage down in storage
i'll hold this end i'll hold this on
help jimmy jimmy needs more help than i
oh get out of here chris he just called
me not an epic gamer i'd rather die than
be called not an epic gamer
do they spawn in here or something ah
three
two
one all right it is officially round
three chandler's respawning so we're
faster they're faster things are about
to get injured
carl there's just no chance everybody's
got to get an electrical
oh my gosh they're so fast holy cow
chandler
oh i died you died where are you
no did i die oh ah okay wait chris is
dead it's just me and chill where you
guys are at
okay chandler we have to stick the spot
we have to stick the spot really hard oh
you watch uh left side we'll get you to
respawn we got this it'll be all your
guys's fault if we don't get to respawn
so no pressure yeah we gotta get the
boys back we gotta get the boys back and
i think we need to go to the other
sections let's go to communications
right now come on whoa
okay we're in comms shoot the other side
like this like i'm doing
try and get through this
dude the bullets are flying past me and
hitting people beside me
all right hurry come back come back come
on click dude my hand is so tired 50
more seconds until the next round and me
and chris come back
chandler chillers
can you do me a favor
i'm staying i'm staying alive look at
these bodies stacking 25 seconds left oh
my gosh are you clutch 20 seconds of
course i'm clutch call me eli manning
baby pay attention 10 seconds the round
ends which means chris yeah we should
probably go back to our computer
hurry up my hand is gonna cramp oh god
they're camping my body it is now round
four the zombies are now faster boys we
have this round and the round five if we
survive both we win go go go go
oh they're so bad they're so fast
everybody come to memphis please holy
cow i haven't died yet i haven't died
yet oh my gosh i have a strategy
come on
oh that was so close hey guys i'm gonna
be risky i'm the only one that hasn't
died yet so i feel like i'm gonna have
some fun this round i wonder what would
happen if i just did this you'll die
that's what's gonna happen jimmy i don't
know if you noticed let's see ah he got
close
i died
jail or fall back you gotta be focused i
gotta scan i gotta scan oh oh okay
oh oh oh what are you doing ah get away
get away get away get away
i'm scared chris chris chris help watch
my sticks all right we can't stay still
we gotta keep moving someone's watching
security camps all right i'll go get
them
no we can't leave each other we can't oh
i died i died gosh dang it i'm in the
corner
live odd for us um
um
oh my god they're so fast oh he's behind
me what the what the heck i'm sorry i
got a camp i gotta be campy dude i can't
even get out of here chris where are you
i'm in electrical now here's my dead
body as a distraction i'm in reactor
they're waiting for me outside the door
i hope my ak doesn't overheat
[Music]
all right screw this you guys can't
touch me you can tell who the sweaty
kids are trying to challenge me jayla
get in here
i made it they're so bold all right i
brought my my train over here all right
chandler we can hold this down we can do
this just us all right ah
oh he had to get by you didn't even go
for you i was about to scratch my nose i
thought you had it and then you went up
to at the top they want me they look at
them hold on don't you yeah see who they
go for if you don't shoot
now we now are stuck here up what's up
what's up go left oh whoa i'm dead oh oh
louie it's only chandler can he clutch
it
i got it no
no we cannot no we cannot clutch it
since taylor just died that means we
lost well i didn't have ray gun i really
hope you guys enjoyed this modded among
us was a lot of fun if you want more
comment down below hit the subscribe
button bye